et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre-jean terne amiens président du
rsp s ur ps pardon médecins libéraux
j'ai du mal avec les acronymes
d'auvergne et rhône-alpes instance donc
qui fédère 1700 médecins de la région
morgan dallas 14000 14000 d'accord
valeurs petites erreurs de tous les
médecins réservation très bien 14001
médecins de la région
morgane dallas créateur du collectif sos
cafés hôtels restaurants discothèques
vous êtes d'ailleurs le gérant d'une
discothèque toujours fermée inutile de
le préciser
à béthune merci à vous également d'être
la réaction tout d'abord à l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron pierre jeantet
remaniant plutôt soulagé satisfait au
contraire frustré ce soir soulagé non
rassurés par le fait qu'on a on va dire
une décélération progressive qui permet
de protéger la population avec par
contre on va dire beaucoup
d'interrogations sur ce qui nous attend
à partir on va dire de début janvier ses
terres la vaccination ou là c'est un peu
le saut dans l'inconnu en fonction du
type de vaccin qui seront disponibles on
a absolument aucun recul sur des
technologies virale l'on va dire de type
iron wade n ça n'a jamais été validé et
là je suis un peu sceptique puisque on
n'est pas en capacité d'avoir un
registre vaccinale en france même si on
en a les moyens depuis des années avec
le cas des vaccinations électronique est
toujours pas implémenter et qu'on nous
parle actuellement d'un carnet papier ou
avec la cnam donc on marche sur la tête
dans cette opération sur ses vaccins où
on aura probablement beaucoup d'effets
indésirables et on sera dans
l'incapacité de les récupérer
or déjà les français sont pas très
favorables à la vaccination valcy
humaine engouement pour la grippe mais
je crains fort que l'adhésion de la
population soit très mitigé vu les
interrogations qu'on à a répondu d'une
certaine manière à ce scepticisme
et français la vaccination ne sera pas
obligatoire c'est une bonne réponse
selon vous alors c'est une bonne réponse
parce que de toute manière les français
ont un mauvais taux de vaccination on
est gêné dans le pire des cas 75 % si on
veut être réaliste on a encore en france
on est quand même dans un des pays et se
disant les plus évoluées de la planète
avec une rougeole qui circulent chaque
hiver on a eu des épisodes de rougeole
sur le couloir rhônalpins et en paca
l'an dernier il ya eu un mort on paie en
à l'ouest en loire qu'on aurait pu
éviter si on avait une couverture
vaccinale on est dans l'incapacité alors
que certains autres pays sont beaucoup
plus en avance que nous à avoir je le
répète un registre vaccinale et surtout
avec une mesure des effets indésirables
et il ya eu de reçu ou à venir une
lenteur administrative caricaturale de
la france sur l'absence de prise en
compte de d'un tel registre qui serait
quand même une ne alors qu'il est
disponible
quand même de savoir ça fait des années
que ça existe mais toujours pas être
présenté alors je me retourne vers
morgan dalle qui doit certainement
peut-être qu'il est sceptique mais doit
l'espérer ce vaccin parce qu'il
semblerait que ce soit la seule solution
pour vous libérer voulait les gérants de
deux discothèques mangane dalle votre
première réaction à ces annonces avec
une lueur d'espoir au bout du tunnel la
date du 20 janvier pour ceux que vous
défendez les cafés les hôtels et
restaurants et les discothèques si les
conditions ne permet votre réaction
alors tout d'abord bon je vous avoue que
nous étions un peu à peu sans voix est
complètement dans la compréhension de
cette date parce que le casse janvier
pour nous c'est beaucoup trop tard même
si on est très satisfait de la situation
sanitaire actuelle donc là fléchissement
de la coupe des capots vide mais on se
pose la question de comment allons-nous
survivre économiquement
je pense que
c'est beaucoup trop tard pour nous alors
on nous avons conscience qu'il y a qu il
ya un état sanitaire et qu' il faut être
très attentif et pour éviter que ça
redémarre mais elles ont qu'allons-nous
faire des morts économique et je pense
que ça va être très compliqué dans l'est
dans les semaines pour tous les
commerçants je pense qu'on va rester sur
le carreau tout le tout le secteur des
cafés hôtels restaurants discothèques
vont vont être sur le carreau je
n'espère pas mais je pense qu'on aura
autant de autant de drames que pour le
coc vidal point de vue soda point de vue
socio-économique
je me tourne vers le médecin on imagine
voilà que vous comprenez humide
humainement le désarroi de morgane dalle
c'est une mesure qui pour le médecin que
vous êtes est justifié néanmoins
jusqu'au 20 janvier il va falloir en
tout cas patienter pour tout ce qui est
restaurants bars et évidemment
discothèque alors moi je vais je vais
même en rajouter une couche
parce que le 20 janvier il faut pas
penser que la vaccination sur le
territoire français donc si on a un
effet de la vaccination c'est
probablement fin février début mars
or ce que ce qu'a dit monsieur est très
justes économiquement ils sont déjà
morts et ça va le faire que s'accentuer
donc l'effet de la vaccination penser
que le 20 janvier
on va avoir un effet de la vaccination
alors à côte deux vaccins disponibles et
sur des souches arn un processus de
fabrication arn me semble on va dire
plus qu'utopique pour ajouter le fait
que actuellement si vous avez un cas
positif
vous devez renseigner le système
informatique alors imaginé par la paix
de paris des hôpitaux de paris
c'est géré par la cnam ce système ne
marche pas ce système est défaillant
donc actuellement
quand on entend une stratégie qui nous
dit je teste prendre ça sert on y arrive
et encore avec un délai qui commence on
nous promet que début janvier ne savent
pas résolu deuxièmement alerté très bien
alerté le problème c'est qu'il faut
rentrer des informations dans s'il est
ça ne fonctionne pas vous allez avoir
une avalanche de test alors qu'on est
pour l'instant encore
pic de tests déjà avec le volume actuel
ça ne marche pas donc comment vous allez
faire pour pouvoir gérer le deuxième
critère qui est d'alerter la population
troisième point vous allez vouloir
protéger alors là c'est vrai qu'il ya un
gros effort des collectivités on va dire
des régions des départements pour le
faire mais surtout sur la vaccination
faut pas se leurrer c'est fin mars début
avril qu'on a réellement un impact
en attendant il y aura pas mal de gens
on voit bien si vous voulez moi je
prends l'exemple de ma région on a
actuellement juste titre une
décélération du président
on a quand même une augmentation du
nombre de patients en réanimation qui ne
sont pas des patients qu'aux vides
habituellement sur la région robert
grenade c'est de l'ordre de 250
on est à plus de 300 patients alors
prenez pointe si vous voulez on a des
patients qui ont des infarctus du
myocarde
on est des patients qui ont des avis des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux et des
patientes ont fait des tentatives de
suicide est plutôt sur l'ouest de la
région
c'est à dire la vallée du gier la vallée
de la loire la zone de clermont ferrand
et puis on a aussi des patients alors là
j'ai écouté je ne comprends pas au monde
initialement sur ce que vous dites les
suicides
vous avez observé une augmentation
significative qui voulut être liés à
cette situation d'ailleurs emmanuel mais
pas à parler en fin de cet aspect
psychologique était très compliqué mais
ça se traduit en rien madame ça se
traduire en réa vous avez une marche qui
est encore assez étroit qui commence à
se desserrer sur le nombre de ligues
dont on dispose en animations encore
vides mais par contre on voit monter
inexorablement les patients qui ne sont
pas atteints de comme idée qui ont
besoin de réanimation
donc on a un delta de plus de 68
maintenant à la hausse sur la région
rhône alpes morgane dalle on en parle
beaucoup de cet aspect voilà
psychologique
j'imagine que vous et vos confrères ça
devient extrêmement compliqué
aujourd'hui clairement quelles sont les
aides dont vous disposez emmanuel macron
a évoqué un chiffre d'affaires jusqu'à
20% du chiffre d'affaires de 2 2019 des
subventions pardon est-ce que c'est par
exemple une mesure qui pourrait
significativement vous soulager votre
profession on sait pas suffisant c'est
pas suffisant certes ça pourra aider
l'idée était d'avoir 30 % du chiffre
d'affaires d'affaires pardon et nous
constatons que les différents syndicats
et plus largement les citoyens n'ont
toujours pas été n'ont toujours pas été
consultés donc c'est à dire que c'est
encore une décision je présume du
conseil de défense
on ne consulte toujours pas des français
on ne consulte toujours pas les
professionnels concernés les 20% c'est
que ce sera pas suffisant d'autant plus
que depuis plusieurs mois nous avons
fonctionné en mode dégradé et nous avons
été fermé sans vraiment de avoir de
grosse indemnisation de quelle façon
allons-nous nous à démoniser on sait que
le cadre était déjà très restrictif
d'autant plus quand on parle de l'amener
2019 mais que se passe-t-il si haut en
2019 nous étions fermés surtout on sait
que en 2019 les chiffres d'affaires
avait été amputé par différentes crises
sociales pourquoi ne pas avoir pris le
meilleur mois des trois des trois
dernières années il ya le choix avec
l'indemnisation jusqu'à 10000 euros par
mois avantageux pour les petites pme les
pme en tout cas selon le chef de l'état
ça peut être intéressant quand même on
vous oui bien bien entendu on ne va pas
cracher dessus ça peut être intéressant
mais ça ne résout pas tout quid de la
valeur des fonds de commerce
ça ça va rester un gros problème qu'en
est il de la valeur des fonds de
commerce
on n'a pas réglé ce problème on a
consulté personne c'est à dire que nos
fonds de commerce ne valent plus rien
entre guillemets on est prise en otage
il y avait des personnes soit contrainte
ou perdre pour de mars mars avril mai
juin où nous n'avons rien toucher et si
je prends par exemple plus
particulièrement le cas des discothèques
qui eux pour septembre octobre novembre
n'ont pas encore été indemnisées
donc comment ces gens là vont ils vivre
comment font-ils bouillir la marmite
en réalité il ya énormément de
problématiques auxquelles on ne répond
pas j'ai l'impression que la casserole
d'état ébullition et on met une plaque
de plomb dessus je pense que tout ça va
très mal finir on va on va à l'essai
des commerçants sur le carreau c'est à
dire qu'on a on avait pour l'habitude
enfin certains politiciens d'appeller
gilet jaune laissant dans les
commerçants je pense que vont finir son
travail mais nous il va nous rester des
dents et je pense qu'on va mordre très
fort parce qu'on restera pas sur le
carreau on assistera pas sans rien faire
à la diminution à la disparition pardo
de nos fonds de commerce
ensuite une question me taraude verra ce
qu'on arrive à la fin de ce débat merci
question me taraude pourquoi les
espagnols eux ont fait un autre choix
notre choix pour leur commerce
on est bientôt les anglais également
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas avoir fait les
mêmes choix peut-être que le mac ça
aurait pu me répondre
abbas a malheureusement il est pas il
n'est pas au gouvernement encore mais
mais merci on vous le souhaite
peut-être jean-pierre un terme à nyon ou
pas merci merci à tous les deux en tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous pour réagir à
ces annonces des manuels macron